et pour terminer ce journal petit tour
en voie de nuit le nouveau tube de l'été
c'est bien sûr la lambada à la fin de
l'été un million de disques sans doute
sera vendu la lambada
c'est un disque mais c'est aussi une
danse et dans la région vous allez le
voir ça marche comme ailleurs c'est au
brésil que la lambada est devenu un
véritable phénomène de société le
cocktail et simple sinon explosif à ceux
plutôt torride sur fond bien sûr
tropicale sans oublier une forte dose de
sensualité la contagion a gagné notre
région sans mal à marseille par exemple
la lambada s'affiche partout pour le
moment qu'on danse avec les moyens du
bord on essaye surtout d'imiter les
danseurs d'un fameux clip
je pense qu'il s'est plutôt de sans
pareil personne ne sait vraiment dans le
sahara là bas des légendes en cela par
couple et s'éclate score tout simplement
à votre avis la lambada a de l'avenir
devant devant elle je pense je pense je
pense on a est une musique d'origine
latine vous savez le pays la tête et je
pense que dans la région et à madame
grand avenir
techniquement puisqu'il faut aussi
parler technique à lambada est un savant
mélange de salsa et de begin a le
nouveau ticket chic et choc il a été
lancé comme un véritable produit apprend
renfort de publicité qui paie photos
plutôt évocatrice toujours est-il qu'il
colle parfaitement au climat
méditerranéen chaud et surtout sensuelle
regardez vous
et peut-être un petit blocage au niveau
du bassin pour pour pour les hommes je
crois que les filles d'assumer la
lambada
mais ça va changer peut-être il faut
être décontracté qu'il faut pas
confondre tirs
je laisse se débrouiller tout seul toit
j'aime aussi
ce côté ce qui est essentiel et
c'est vraiment sur scène la lambada est
perçu aujourd'hui comme une véritable
mode reste à savoir maintenant si elle
passera au nom l'été à vous d'en décider
à
comment